ok this is working I bought myself a
selfie stick and
and
Young Gun and in fact behind me is our
canada canadian Oh from Richmond I don't
know what didn't link lava finna Bochy
till now lean lava
I'm enjoying me some specious auspicious
oh yes are you showing one species with
yes that's I'm enjoying it here nice
weather to nice people very nice beach
so you are alone well no I have my wife
in hotel there I can see how to do I
wanna take a video of myself
arrived yesterday
me arrived yesterday so today's my first
day yes so how do you find our country
very nice very nice here you go very
friendly she went to the temple went to
shwedagon everybody with the spinners
farming base yes hello and everybody
gets we respect you because you come
money for all over our country oh well
I'm happy I'm happy to give my here it's
worth it worth it how come you speak
English so well why do you speak English
so well you speak English very well I
was in Poland country oh really oh
really in India in India oh yes okay now
here's where it went to the temple sri
doggone temple sweet sweet gurgaon she
see that the temple people to go golden
10 12 cool I been I went this morning oh
you're very nice it contains about 70
tons of growth Wow 70 tons of gold so
many turns of cool wow it was nice
because everybody yes sacrifices give
donation of gold yes so that in the next
match yes we believe in that slide 9 and
0 in the next lab yeah we're in a better
put together possession maybe maybe or
may not be allowed who knows nobody has
every knows how many came back to tell
us then nobody came back and cold oh
he's there is nobody yet and that's only
for makes you happy so why do I believe
whether true or not okay anyways hope I
started thank you very much thank you ok
bye bye come on
I had a visitor there No
kind of puts a shaft on my face I'm not
very good at doing this so I can walk
along here with my new toy and of course
it was nice to meet with that gentleman
of course the you know we were in in
Seoul for one night and a good part of a
day and of course the amazing thing in
all these countries is how different
than cultures are in Korea how energetic
everyone isn't very very friendly and
here
bus there people are so friendly and
always go for the temple everybody's
smiling at us the kids very good nature
this is the impression you get now
there's a over there you'll see that
there's a group of monks there you can
perhaps just make them out if I spring
around there we go and all we can't see
them anyway behind me here you have the
lake and yeah I mean this is again I can
have to get used to this one take in
Hanoi we should have a meetup so whether
you are get the Me's or you teach
English or you order living there and
enjoying it let's meet up and again as
to what the best date for the meet I'm
going to be there from the 10th to the
18th so maybe he's somewhere around the
middle 13th 14th or so March let me know
what dates work for you and in Seoul
we're going to try to aim for I believe
it was
20th in the evening which is a which is
a friday because the 21st is our last
night we're going to be with our friends
and then we return on the twenty-second
back to Canada so now I'm going to see
with my remote if I can turn this off I
think it no I kept for every our first
night in Seoul need to be there
boiling hot on the feet
Wow
Carmen look up there
I know I know
the weight is a lot better than the
black I'll tell you